睡觉的时候有点失眠，
我听那个鲁豫老师和一个叫张春的作者他俩的聊天，
我也深刻的意识到，
现在有很多抑郁症的患者啊，
真的是挺难的，
因为很多抑郁症的患者，
他就是无时无刻都想要结束自己的生命，
无时无都想要离开这个世界，
真的很难，
但是人家那个张冲老师他也是有一段时间是有抑郁，
他就说他有一天突然想明白了一个道理，
什么道理呢？
他说我们都会死的，
你不自也会死的，
着什么急呢？
我的理解是这样，
早死又不会拿奖金，
晚死又不会被奉款，
我为什么要那么早的着急死，
这是第一，
第二，
如果这个世间的爱没有办法留住我的话，
如果没有那么多人爱我，
我也没有那么大的能力去爱别人，
那就让愤怒来支撑我，
我有时候想，
如果有一天我抑郁了，
我要干什么？
我想到了之后，
我觉得天地开阔，
如果有一天我连死都不怕了，
我还怕什么？
我如果说没有什么东西是值得我眷恋的，
那我就天天骂，
那些尸位素餐的，
那些欺上瞒下的，
那些欺凌弱小的，
那些贪污工程款的，
搞得工程楼塌了的，
桥塌了的，
我挨个骂，
我一个一个骂，
而且我一年365天，
我可以300天用来骂人，
65天我用来学习，
学什么，
我怎么骂不用承担法律责任，
我怎么骂能让他身败名裂？
我怎么骂能让这个影响力更大，
我怎么骂才能够能一针见？
辟写争砭实壁，
才能骂够深刻，
才能骂的千古流芳。
姐妹们，
如果你现在处于这种抑郁的状态的话，
你可以去听一下严中花束，
鲁意老师和张春老师他们那一期可能对你会有帮助。
我自己的这刚坑这一段真的是我昨天晚上没有睡着觉，
我心里想的问题，
反正大家都得死，
我着什么急，
我不着急，
我不自查，
我也得死，
只要你不做任何动作，
你就死不了。
这段时间活的不好就瞎活一阵，
你本能的你饿了，
你知道要吃东西，
你本能的你渴了，
你知道要喝水，
只要你没有多余的动作，
你就死不了。
如果爱没有办法留住你的话，
就让你心里面的愤怒留住你，
我就天天骂，
就那些为了自己的利益是别人的生命与不顾的，
什么那个政客贪污了多少工程款，
什么那种欺上瞒下的把老百姓的取暖费都给贪污了的，
什么那种一些儿童的变态，
什么那种欺凌弱小的自己有什么不顺心的事儿了，
跑到幼儿园去起朋友的，
哎，
个人骂我天天骂，
我逮着一个我要骂到他身败名裂，
我着一个我要骂到他这辈子啊，
都抬不起头。
我不知道我直播间有多少抑郁的姐妹能听进去，
如果我连死都不怕了，
我就要让愤怒把我留下，
反正早晚大家都得死，
我不着急死，
虽然说我真的有一天抑郁了，
我不怕死，
但是我怕失去自由啊，
我怕不自由，
所以我得学习一下怎么骂我不用坐牢，
怎么骂才能针砭实地，
怎么骂才能骂到他身败名裂，
骂到这辈子？
不起头怎么骂才能宣泄一下我心中的正义？
记得点赞关注哦。